das ist wirklich nicht gut auf der
internationalen raumstation iss gab es
offensichtlich einen sabotageakt das
liegt das letzte woche aufgetaucht ist
wurde nicht durch einen materialfehler
oder ein stark eines meteoriten
verursacht sondern durch ein von einem
menschen gebohrtes loch wie bitte was
ist passiert und was sind jetzt vor
allem die konsequenzen klick zum
zeitpunkt schon herzlich willkommen gar
nicht gut gar nicht gut was ist da oben
los und das schlimme scheinbar scheint
es keiner so richtig zu wissen die
fakten vergangene woche donnerstag wurde
ein leck in der raumstation iss
festgestellt stück für stück wurden die
shots der module geschlossen um den ort
der undichtigkeit einzugrenzen
schließlich stieß die besatzung auf ein
loch in einer angedockten sojus-kapsel
und zwar genau der mit der alexander
gerst am 6 juni zur iss gestartet war
die suris ms09 erst wurde ein
produktionsfehler ein metroid oder
einriss vermutet noch was jetzt
öffentlich wurde lässt einem das blut in
den adern gefrieren und das ist absolut
keine übertreibung ein ehemaliger
kosmonaut hat sich dazu jetzt zu wort
gemeldet maxim surajew äußert die sehr
beunruhigende vermutung dass ein
besatzungsmitglied je sabotiert hat der
staatlichen nachrichtenagentur ria
nowosti sagte er dass es nicht
ausgeschlossen werden könne dass ein
besatzungsmitglied zitat diese seltsame
nummer abgezogen hat wir sind alle
menschen und jeder könnte nach hause
wollen
die nasa hat die aufnahme des lochs
inzwischen aus dem netz genommen wohl
weil sie ziemlich erschreckend ist wie
haben sie aus dem netz gefischt und
können hier die wirklich schlimmen
details zeigen man sie deutlich dass bei
der sabotage mehrfach versucht wurde
anzusetzen der bohrer ist mehrere male
abgerutscht bevor dann griff und das
loch bohrt die besatzung fand das loch
letzte woche und konnte mit epoxidharz
und einem tuch flicken was kosmos
direktor dmitri rogozin wurde erst in
mailand und missstände beim sojus
programm zu beseitigen
jetzt ist es noch schlimmer diese
sabotage macht raumfahrt hinzu
kunst extrem unsicher die frage ist
immer noch wer konkret hat das getan
die spekulationen schießen in den
letzten stunden ins kraut raumfahrt
journalist eric berger meint zu wissen
dass es indizien gebe dass der schaden
bereits auf der erde entstand er
behauptet dass ein techniker diesen bohr
fehler sei mit leim verschloss wodurch
ihr baywa kommt es nicht auffiel
ok mai soll dann drei monate vakuum im
weltraum standgehalten haben wo sind die
lyme spuren was kostenlos chef franco
sie entschließt schlamperei nicht aus
aber eben auch zitat eine andere version
die wir nicht ausschließen eine
absichtliche störung im weltall auch
rogosin hat mehrere versuche
festgestellt ein loch in die sojus
kapsel zu bohren sie seien mit
zögerlicher hand ausgeführt worden
das ist wirklich keine gute situation
und spricht eigentlich alles dafür dass
das loch dort oben gebohrt wurde
was ist da oben also gerade los wie soll
der täter gefunden werden was sind die
konsequenzen muss das sojus programm
eingestellt werden wird die space
extraction krug apfel jetzt schneller
zum einsatz kommen so etwas ist wirklich
eine absolute katastrophe und wenn es
sich bewahrheitet das erste mal
überhaupt dass im weltall sabotiert
wurde wir halten euch hier auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video dazu und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann abonniert klick so genau die glocke
nicht vergessen
dafür klicken folgt mir auf whatsapp da
gibt es die videos früher da stehe ich
euch vorher nachricht dafür hier klicken
keine werbung mehr auf clips um gibt es
wenn ihr mitglied werdet der linkes
unter dem video wir danken schon mal für
diese unterstützung und wenn der link
dann nicht es war am computer anschauen
und hier geht es weiter mit der wettlauf
ins weltall
bis dann bleibt dran